[Music]
as climate change progresses the
infrastructure and supply chains of
businesses that were built to withstand
prior historical conditions
are today becoming vulnerable to the
increasingly frequent and heavy
precipitation events
also extreme temperatures
rising sea levels and intense climate
hazards
and so resilience planning and strategic
investment helps organizations ensure
that their systems continue to deliver
reliable performance in the face of
changing climates
so in the next few minutes let's learn
how we could approach this data problem
where we need to combine multiple
streams of private public and
third-party data to derive predictive
insights in order to dive in let's focus
on a specific use case such as analyzing
wildfire risk for an electricity
transmissions operator
do you know that any business can use
the same process similarly for other
types of climate hazards
great and so from this let's first start
by defining the time frame for our
planning period long-term multi-year
analysis is important for maintenance
forecasting and replacing existing
infrastructure but a lot can change
it's also incredibly helpful from a
crisis response perspective to analyze
for example the spread of wildfire in
the next 24 hours
for climate risk analysis the sweet spot
is looking at the upcoming weeks and
months
to both encompass emergency planning and
mitigation per season so this will be
our goal with that in mind the ideal
output is a map that shows areas of high
risk of wildfire that could impact
electrical operations and nearby
communities and also offer preventative
recommendations such as removing brush
from this area and from that area
roger that so then let's assess then
what kind of information we're going to
need like a recipe almost we'll need the
following data ingredients
a dataset that is labeled with areas of
risky plant vegetation that can fuel a
fire
this is key in order to predict the
probability of a fire
we will also need several datasets for
different land and weather conditions
such as elevation and wind patterns
since these factors can help predict
fire direction on slopes
humidity soil moisture precipitation and
the minimum and maximum temperatures by
week or by month for example
awesome with that in mind let's now dive
into the process here's the
architectural diagram
for starters we will need label data
which we can find either online or have
teams or partner organizations manually
labeling data if it's very niche
labeled data means having tags for a
wide variety of examples
we ideally want a balanced data set
containing around the same number of
examples for each kind of tag
as an example we go to our local
firefighters office and ask them about
wildfire risk in the area they hand us a
printed map with high and low risk areas
on different seasons we then go back to
our computers
and use mapping software like google
maps or earth engine for example
to create polygons in a map from the
highlighted regions
next we select a thousand or more random
points that are of high risk and another
1 000 low risk points to avoid bias when
we feed these examples to an ml model in
a bit
next we want the elevation and weather
data along with our fire risk labels so
using data flow which is a scalable data
processing tool we fetch data from earth
engines public data sets that can come
from different satellite bands and next
because we want the model to analyze
images rather than individual points we
also fetch the surrounding pixels of
each point to create examples of high
and low risk pixel patches for our model
using the earth engine's function ee dot
image.getdownload url to request the
data
now two cool things to call out here for
you
one is that earth engine normalizes all
these different geospatial data sources
to enable us to work with the same
format
and the second thing is that data flow
helps us auto scale all these data
requests that we are making to earth
engine so they all happen in parallel
reducing the time from hours to minutes
which is beautiful
awesome
also note that if we want weekly
predictions we need the data from the
prior weeks and similarly we need the
prior months data for monthly
predictions
now we have examples of high and low
risk areas including the weather and
satellite data
we're almost ready to train a model
next data flow splits the training
examples into two data sets
one with the majority of the examples
for the model to learn and adjust and
the other for the model to validate on
data it has never seen before
and as a friendly note one of our
favorite frameworks in our developer
youtube series called people and planet
ai is that we use convolutional neural
networks or cnns as our go-to when
working with satellite data because they
work just like our eyes they analyze
images and find patterns for us
cnns are great for training a model
based on images because it infers
context from the arrangement of pixels
without having you to explicitly tell it
exactly
and so next we use tensorflow keras
which is a powerful ml library to define
our model and create our training script
which we use to train the model in
vertex ai which is an ai managed
platform
note that in vertex ai we will choose
tpu or gpu processing chips for this ai
workload because it significantly
shortens the training time over regular
vms
exactly and next we play with the model
until we're happy with the results
for example we can have the model
predict the fire risk of the same map we
got from the firefighter experts and
compare how well it did
once we're happy with the model
we host it in cloud run as an online
prediction service
cloudrun is an easy to use managed web
platform it only uses resources per
request instead of having machines
running 24 hours a day and it's also
available in low carbon footprint
regions
now to visualize the predictions in a
useful and actionable way this is the
creative part and where the magic begins
i agree
and we can initially prototype this in a
collab notebook
or create a wildfire map layer in earth
engines editor called a mask
but eventually we can build this out in
a formal map like web app that labels
pixels from zero to one
zero being of no risk to one being high
risk and colors them appropriately to
pop out
we could even filter for high risk areas
that are surrounding electrical
infrastructure we can also show
scorecards with summaries of the risk
analysis
we can even filter by date or show a
month by month visual based on average
historical weather to see for example
what does july compare to versus january
and from a reporting summary we could
also have these visuals stored as images
into cloud storage and automatically
exported into a google slides
presentation
and there you have it
a quick walkthrough on one way to do
wildfire risk analysis
other hazards can be done in a similar
way we just need the right data
so what's next if you want to learn more
we have a notebook with all the code you
need it goes step by step on how to
create an ai model that generates land
cover maps
they help to keep track of changes on
the earth like deforestation or urban
growth you can also follow us more in
our people and planet ai episodes which
i have linked below with other helpful
resources
cheers bye
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you